en un gobierno como el ruso cuál puede
ser el verdadero objetivo de este
bloqueo y que tanto afecta a la
población realmente son las redes más
usadas en esa nación
bueno gracias por la invitación en
realidad es un gesto significativo si
bien la presencia e influencia del redes
como facebook no es la misma de rusia de
lo que podría ser en países de este lado
del mundo pero no deja de ser importante
por por el principio de control del
discurso es muy claro que para moscú lo
importante es tener control de una
narrativa que en sus medios es una sola
en donde no caben voces disidentes pero
que a través de recursos como facebook o
como twitter pues se escuchan muchas
otras voces disonantes y lo que quiere
es tratar de mantener el control sin
embargo es la primera vez que nosotros
vemos una situación relativamente grande
con un gobierno como el ruso haciendo
presión para que las redes normalmente
lo que no se extiende en presión para
que bajen contenidos en este caso está
haciendo presión para que mantenga
arriba y no oculte contenidos que les
son favorables a la vista demás bueno
hace algunos días cuando ya había
iniciado la invasión expertos dijeron
que para rusia era conveniente mantener
el acceso a las redes sociales y no
cortar la internet en ucrania a qué se
debe esta estrategia
si hay una teoría que dice que el
rechazo a la medida que es vista tan
puntualmente tan incontrovertiblemente
como una movida autoritaria de control
de la información podría causar este
muchas más pérdidas que lo que se diga
en portales en contrarios a la visión
oficial básicamente la gente que consume
canales estatales o portales que
reproducen lo que dice el kremlin pues
se va a seguir informando en otras
plataformas de lo mismo y no es
realmente lo afectado pero el otro
porcentaje de personas que no consume
esa información pero se entera de que
fue suspendida en una red como twitter
como facebook verían en esa medida
validada su creencia de que lo que está
haciendo el kremlin falta a la verdad
falta la justicia falta a los principios
de un estado de derecho eso es lo que
dicen algunos analistas sin embargo en
estos momentos lo que ha preferido a
moscú es analizar todo desde su
perspectiva de control a la censura y
represalias por lo que dicen ellos es un
trato injusto con sus medios resultado
al final es el mismo